welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Incredible Hulk is finally
streaming on Disney plus and since so
many things from this movie are coming
back in next year's Captain America
Brave New World Tim Blake Nelson as the
leader Thaddeus Ross is a rumored Red
Hulk with Tyler's Betty Ross is
returning and since we've learned so
much about Bruce Banner as a character
in She-Hulk we thought we have to
revisit the 2008 Hulk for Clues details
we missed before and an explanation of
why this movie is now able to stream on
Disney's platform so let's dive in and
new rockstars is now three channels this
main channel for Easter egg breakdowns
my channel the Deep dive for deeper
analyzes the classic titles and the
break room which is our new home for our
inside Marvel reactions subscribe to all
three and support us with one of our
shirts from nerd riot.shop okay we open
our logo that we're not used to seeing
in front of a Marvel movie Universal
Pictures bit of History here in the
1990s Universal bought the rights to two
characters from Marvel The Hulk and
Neymar the Submariner Neymar made his
MCU debut in 2022's Black Panther Recon
forever the universal made two Hulk
movies the 2003 Ang Lee Eric Bana film
and this 2008 film as part of Marvel
Studios official launch coming out in
the same month as the first Iron Man
film but the rights to the whole
character are believed to have shifted
back fully to Marvel as of June 2023
assuming a 15-year licensing period
under the terms of the Paramount deal
that Universal also seem to have made
according to a 2006 SEC filing so the
2008 hold film came out in June 2008 15
years later June 2023 and that might
explain why this Incredible Hulk film is
now suddenly available on Disney plus so
over these credits we get an abbreviated
recap of this Hulk's origin all of the
visuals were actually recreated from the
70s and 80s Hulk TV show intro like we
see Banner in some sort of science chair
getting bombarded with gamma rays a
green laser on his head then we see him
Hulk out but from a first person point
of view injury and Betty Ross and her
father Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross but in
the wreckage next to Betty we see a
science box with a label that reads
Titan in the comics Titan is a villain
who has been described as the Hulk's
Hulk monster that the Hulk turns into
when he gets angry Thunderbolt Ross says
they blood red hand here perhaps a nod
to his Comics alter ego and perhaps his
eventual form the Red Hulk Ross
reappeared in Captain America's Civil
War after a long absence talking about a
heart attack that he had that led to an
epiphany and transformation Harrison
Ford will be taking on the character in
the upcoming Captain America Brave New
World due to William hurt's death in
2022. we find out later that everything
we're seeing Bruce go through here is
part of the same super soldier
experiment that Thaddeus Ross has always
overseen amongst a pile of research we
see a book inventory of rare and
endangered tracheophyta of Amazonia it's
probably a resource that Bruce is using
to look for a cure to his hulking down
in South America there's also a report
of some sort of military organization
having obtained hair and saliva samples
this harvesting of Hulk Blood and Tissue
will become a recurring effort
continuing through shield and presumably
in Captain America Brave New World we
are currently seeing it by the Scrolls
in secret Invasion as they harvest
enhanced tissue from various sources to
make super Scrolls also when it could be
to scream we see a notice for a
requisition requests made to Stark
Industries we see Tony Stark at the end
of the film approaching Thaddeus Ross
about his whole program I'm tying this
all in with the Avengers Initiative
there are also some schematics for this
truck with a big cannon doodad on the
top this is the Sonic Cannon the Army
will use to fight the Hulk on the
college campus later in the movie it's
actually the same exact technology that
will later appear in the MCU on war
machine's armor when he uses it in the
airport battle in Civil War and on
Mysterio's drones in Spider-Man far from
home used on the tower bridge in London
there's a quick flash of a
correspondence intercepted message
letting us know that Bruce has been
trying to get a hold of Betty and
various other sources throughout the
academic world but then there's this
Memo from Nick Fury on Shield letterhead
now the events of this Hulk movie take
place during Fury's big week a time
period in the MCU that includes events
from this movie from Iron Man 2 from
Thor and from the final scene of the
first Captain America film this is a big
week that ultimately leads to the
creation of the Avengers I also like
that this memo uses the term Threat
Level red because as we go through this
we're going to look at any clue we can
that might point to the Red Hulk there's
a list of banners known associates
including the name Rick Jones who in the
comics is kind of a sidekick character
who would go on to become a hacker known
as is the Whisperer there's also the
name Leonard Sampson who we actually see
later the character played by Ty Burrell
doc Samson is another important
character from the comics but in this
movie he's a psychiatrist who's dating
Bruce's ex Betty Ross originally this
movie was going to open with an
alternate scene where Bruce tries to
kill himself while we don't see it here
it was referenced in the Avengers and in
scene and so I put a bullet in my mouth
and the other guy spit it out hulk
smashes the ice which causes a Shockwave
that unearths Captain America's shield
in the ice you can actually see it here
if you look closely we catch up with
Bruce meditating to the sound of a
metronome the implication being that
this backstory info dump that we just
saw was taking place inside his head we
hear the faint sound of a heartbeat
gradually slowing down we learned that
Bruce has been hiding out in Rio De
Janeiro Brazil and unusually loud and
crowded City maybe not the perfect place
if you're trying to relax while being
off the grid I mean at any time the Fast
and Furious crew could just roll through
Dragon a giant safe the 2003 Angley Hulk
film left off with Bruce somewhere in
the Amazon rainforest and while this
isn't meant to be an explicit connection
to that timeline it does generally pick
up when where that story left off Bruce
flips around the Brazilian TV and lands
on a clip of the courtship of Eddie's
Father which stars Bill Bixby the same
actor who'd go on to play Banner in The
Incredible Hulk TV show the character
was named David Banner for the TV series
this is one of many nods to that series
that appears in the film Bruce learns
breathing techniques from real life
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Master Rickson
Gracie Edward Norton was extremely
committed to this role both in terms of
his physical discipline and even writing
passes of the screenplay but he was not
given credit by The Writer's Guild for
his contributions this creative
disagreement is something many artists
would find in Marvel Studios over the
year Marvel wants screenwriters and
directors who play ball with their
executive's Vision an actors mostly just
get buff and read the lines with the
exception of a few key ad-libs I am Iron
Man Bruce wears these little glasses
here while he's fixing the machine which
he wears most of the time in the comics
and the Mark Ruffalo version whereas
more often he bleeds some goofy looking
CGI blood into a soda assembly line This
tainted soda doesn't turn people into
hulks but rather just makes him sick we
learn in She-Hulk of the fact that
Jennifer had a transfusion from a family
member his the reason she got super
powers and not just a bad case of the
gamma poops since Bruce is still
learning the language of Portuguese he
doesn't misspeak the classic line okay
even though in Portuguese the word for
hungry and the word for angry are very
different Bruce communicates via
encrypted messages with a Mr Blue using
the code name Mr Green obvious reference
to his alter ego but also a nod to the
color-based code names and Reservoir
Dogs which also starred Tim Roth
Thunderbolt Ross chomping on his
signature cigar gets a report that a man
in Milwaukee who's played by Stan Lee
got gamma poisoning from Bruce's Blood
Soda this is the second MCU film but
it's actually the 10th Stan Lee cameo in
a movie based on Marvel Comics
characters so really Lee making these
kind of cameos totally predated the MCU
he popped up and stuff like the X-Men
movies The Fantastic Four movies and the
Sam Raymond Spider-Man trilogy we
learned that the soda was bottled in
Puerto Verde Brazil Verde of course
means green just a lot of nods to Green
in this movie future Abomination Emile
Blonsky is briefed on Banner after Ross
assembles a Strike Team at Fort Johnson
Fort Johnson named after Kenneth Johnson
creator of the Hulk TV series we learned
that Bruce has been implicated in the
deaths of six people three were probably
in the lab when he changed the first
time but Ross also mentions two Canadian
Hunters so did all expensive time in
Canada or is Ross trying to pin some
other crimes on him Comics Raiders might
hear the country of Canada and
automatically think Canada's own
Wolverine he might have been the one
really responsible for those Wolverine
and Hulk have thrown down on a number of
occasions in the comics the first one
being Incredible Hulk 180. now the MCU
of course did not have X-Men at this
point but it could be a leftover line
from when they thought they were going
to do it in phase one after all one of
feige's alternate pitches for the Iron
Man post credit scene which also came
out this summer of 2008 had Nick Fury
saying this instead as if gamma
accidents radioactive bug bites and
assorted mutants weren't enough so yeah
I guess it's possible
script with that is Ross he had
an Alger Wolverine run around Canada and
he used the threat of the Hulk to cover
his tracks I mean there was also that
headline on the computer screen and she
reported on a man with metal claws
fights in Barbara now in case he weren't
clear on whether or not Blonsky is a
jackass he shoots Bruce's dog now it
seems like it's just a tranq dart but
that off-screen Yelp is enough to make
me still hate this guy all the way
through She-Hulk I'll never forgive him
now Blonsky was absent from the MCU
until a brief cameo in Shang Chi where
we saw his abomination in Alter Ego
getting his butt whipped by Wong in an
underground fighting ring he came back
and She-Hulk with chill new Vibes Haiku
skills a more in-depth backstory the
last we see of him he's following Wong
through a sorcerer portal into
convertage so given how much Marvel has
liked bringing characters from this
movie back in the fold we would not be
surprised to see Tim Roth show up in
either Captain America Brave New World
or maybe the Thunderbolts when I was a
kid cereal was like my main food and now
as an adult most of the cereal I see is
still for kids except magic spoon magic
spoon is cereal reinvented it's the same
great taste that you remember but
upgraded with grown-up ingredients
there's nothing artificial it's high
protein keto friendly gluten-free grain
free soy-free wheat free and naturally
flavored magic spoon cereal has zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
4-5 net grams of carbs in each serving
and only 140 calories per serving if
you're on the go and need a cereal bar
instead each magic spoon cereal bar has
one gram of sugar 10 grams of protein 4
net grams of carbs and only 130 calories
per Bar Magic spoon even lets you pick
your favorite flavors and build your
very own variety box you can choose from
the best-selling cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter and maple waffle flavors
plus other awesome flavors including
honey nuts blueberry muffin birthday
cake and cinnamon roll and you can add
the cookies and cream and cocoa peanut
butter cereal bars to your variety box
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's packed with a 100 happiness
guarantee and if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked and if you're in Canada
or the UK no sweat magic spoon shits to
both so click the link below or scan the
QR code on the screen and use a code new
rockstars for five dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com new rockstars to save
five dollars off your order today Bruce
while hiding from the Army and his work
bullies hulks out properly for the first
time we zoom in on his now green eyes in
the same way as they did in the 1970s TV
show but during this fight scene we only
get glimpses of the Hulk from the
shadows and through the Scopes of the
army guys she's a clever nod to the fact
that the Hulk is more of a monster story
than a superhero movie this whole scene
has classic horror Vibes where the
monster is scarier because you don't
know exactly what it looks like At first
so after this incident Banner makes his
way up through South America through
Central America he walks through the
town and we hear a sad version of the
hitchhiking music from the TV show
we actually see him hitchhiking in the
rain but then we get our first mention
of the World War II super soldier
program that gave us Captain America for
biotech Force enhancement
super soldier so yes a reminder that in
the MCU the origin of the Hulk is rooted
in the same program that yielded Captain
America and hydra's Winter Soldier
program something explored more in the
Falcon the Winter Soldier characters
like Isaiah Bradley the same serum that
the flag Smasher stole and used this
entire wing of characters in the MCU are
connected in a family tree that stems
back to Steve Rogers and Red Skull and
also part of the family tree at least in
the comics is Wolverine Bruce heads to
Stanley's Pizza another nod to Stan Lee
whose real name was Stanley Martin
Lieber the Pizza Chef Stanley here is
played by Canadian actor Paul soles who
voiced Bruce Banner and the 60s animated
series along with several animated
Marvel characters including Spider-Man
Bruce sneaks on campus posing as a pizza
delivery guy Pizza time and he delivers
a pizza to Lou Ferrigno who plays the
security guard of course the bodybuilder
and actor who played the Hulk for in the
classic TV series both Ferrigno and Stan
Lee also had cameos in the Ang Lee Hulk
movie Bruce also gives Pizza to Martin
Starr who later plays Peter Parker's
teacher in Spider-Man homecoming and far
from home and no way home Kevin actually
confirmed that star is playing the same
character in all these movies Betty
stops into Stanley's with Leonard
Simpson it says that she's gotta have a
Mr Pink another not a Reservoir Dogs Mr
Pink was a character played by Steve
Buscemi she ends up spotting Bruce who
isn't being stealthy at all and they
reunite and almost share a kiss in the
rain kisses in the rain something we see
a lot in the Marvel movies Spider-Man
Mary Jane I think we also wanted
Daredevil it's just kind of a thing in
the 2000s the 2000s love to do that
notebook Ross uncovers a cryosync
tank from Stark Industries and the
developer is listed as Dr reinstein
which was the Alisa Dr Erskine used in
the first Captain America film we also
see the words Vita Ray remember he
mentioned Vita Rays as part of the
process that activated the super soldier
serum in Steve Rogers so Blonsky gets
injected with the serum but it's a
slightly different shade of blue than
the dosage at Steve Roger Scott
indicating that things are not gonna go
the same way you can actually hear his
bones crack as they inject him we know
from Steve Rogers screams in that first
cap film how much this procedure hurts
and it shows on blonsky's face here so
on to the campus battle at Culver
University in Virginia serum has already
taken effect Blonsky easily outpaces all
the other soldiers there is a totally
gross moment complete with squelching
noises where Bruce swallows that thumb
drive to avoid Ross getting it
yeah good luck sifting for that later
actually YouTuber John campia has a
cameo as one of the guys firing smoke
canisters he said that he got in trouble
for taking a selfie in costume I mean
hey maybe as with those leaked photos
John posted from no way home he just
thought the movie he was acting in
wasn't real this battle between the Hulk
and the Army was redone in what if
Episode 3 with Mark Ruffalo providing
the voice in the appearance of Bruce
Banner in the Hulk when they reanimated
the sequence they made it ruffalo's
appearance not Norton's so in the mcu's
eyes when we look back at this movie I
guess we should imagine Mark Ruffalo and
not Edward Norton ah this Edward Norton
eraser Bruce hulks out after seeing
Betty get tackled we get a classic Dolly
Zoom shot of everyone's reactions these
two guys filmed this incident we
actually saw this same footage show up
later in Iron Man 2 as part of the same
research that Fury is doing to recruit
The Avengers the guys here are named Jim
Wilson and Jack McGee in the comics Jim
Wilson is Sam Wilson's nephew and a
friend to Bruce Banner Jack McGee is
actually the name of the reporter from
the 1970s 80s TV series who's always
trying to track down the Hulk also in
the comics Jim Wilson's father is get
Gideon Wilson and the character Gideon
Wilson shows up in the She-Hulk series
as a federal prosecutor who sent the
Abomination to prison Hulk picks up a
piece of wreckage and wields it like a
shield another parallel to Captain
America all these super soldiers just
kind of instinctively do this on the
quad they hit him with Stark's Sonic
cannons and Blonsky goes Rogue resulting
in a bone-crunching kick into a tree is
that where you go
Betty calls Hulk Bruce which we know he
usually hates
[Music]
don't mention puny Banner but he seems
okay with it here he actually does seem
to calm down a bit until a helicopter
shoots him with a whole mess of bullets
later on Betty takes Hulk's hand just
like Natasha does later on when she does
her whole the sun's getting real low
lullaby thing in Age of Ultron Betty
throws Bruce a pair of giant purple
pants another Hulk signature clothing
item he shoots them down because this
ain't your daddy's Hulk his pants are
more muted color there's a brief shot of
a news report from whih news this is a
network that pops up throughout the MCU
the Army we see uses Shield server to
look for Bruce we actually see The
Shield logo come up on the screen they
deduce that the Mr Blue he's been
talking to is Dr Samuel Stearns this is
a character with a lot of Marvel history
all of his Comics variants eventually
turn into the leader the green skin big
scold super villain who is the brains
that Hulk is to the brawn an important
figure in the organization known as the
Intelligentsia we see Stearns get a dose
of gamma blood later in this movie a
Twist that will finally pay off in
2024's Captain America World actor Tim
Blake Nelson is confirmed to return and
there have been some set images of this
actor in green makeup on his hands and
arms strongly hinting that his leader
Alter Ego will be one of the big bads of
that movie and we finally meet Dr
Stearns who is appropriately wearing
blue later on Blonsky forces Stearns to
inject him with more of Banner's blood
and we get a shout out of blonsky's
future moniker the mixture could be
Abomination like the Hulk before him we
don't get a good look at Abomination at
first we see his destructive power so
that we are appropriately afraid of him
once a big Throwdown happens they shot
the Harlem scenes in the city of Toronto
they did redecorate it by putting some
things like Harlem's Apollo Theater in
the background but you can still see
some Toronto specifics in the background
The Wire actor Michael K Williams has a
blinking you'll miss the Cameo here he
filmed a longer scene where he tries to
get Hulk and Abomination to stop
fighting but it ended up getting cut but
the actor was reportedly not happy about
Bruce jumps out of the helicopter making
his triumphant dive into the action and
a move that is later parodied in Thor
Ragnarok
the helicopter crashes into a sign for
Williams Plumbing some prominent
Williams in the Marvel Comics include
Simon Williams The Avengers actor wonder
man we're going to meet in the MCU soon
and Ray Ray Williams whom will soon meet
as Iron Heart by Williams is also a
common name I don't know if this
Williams is connected to either of those
but Hulk and Abomination finally brawl
this battle is awesome and it does get
referenced all the time in the various
Netflix series where in Daredevil we see
a newspaper with the headline Harlem
Terror Abomination spits out a tooth
which we will also see Hulk do later in
Age of Ultron when he's fighting Tony in
the Hulkbuster armor if anyone wanted
Hulk DNA or Abomination DNA harvesting
one of these teeth could be a good
source of that in case you're listening
Scrolls Abomination uses his elbow Spike
to stab Hulk through the chest and
throughout the rest of the films
noticeably in Thor Ragnarok you can
actually see that scar on his chest
which is just some really great
attention to detail during this fight
Hulk uses his signature Thunderclap as
well as his Hulk smash move these moves
I think would go on to be underused
throughout the MCU titles but the
Thunderclap did finally return in
She-Hulk and it's pretty great whole
gets the upper hand on Abomination and
he rips out abomination's elbow Spike
and turns the tables on him with a stab
of his own and yes we should note
between this movie and Abominations
return in Shang Chi and its She-Hulk
they did redesign the character the
redesign with the gills and The Greener
color is more consistent with
abomination in the comics in this movie
they definitely desaturated Abomination
so that we could visually tell him apart
from the Hulk but practically in
Universe I think a good explanation is
that these Hulk characters the longer
they stay in their Hulk form gradually
evolve and mature their appearances as
the effects technology gets slightly
better so while in Exile Bruce receives
a package addressed to David B another
not to David Banner his name on the TV
show and in the opening credits we did
see his name listed as Bruce D Banner so
presumably David is his middle name but
the return address is from Milburn pawn
shop for Brad Milburn one of the film
set designers inside is a necklace that
Betty had to sell and Bruce keeps his
promise to get it back to her the final
shot mirrors the shot of Bruce
meditating at the beginning of the film
but now instead of trying to stay calm
and rid himself of the whole curse he is
now working in tandem with the Hulk
embracing his other identity setting up
the great reveal in The Avengers that
he's always angry now the typical post
credit scene actually plays before the
credits this time just kind of on the
other side of the cut to the credit of
the movie Tony Stark visits Ross in a
bar where he tells them that the super
soldier program was put on ice for a
reason and he's always felt that the
hardware was more reliable Stark then
tells him that they're putting a team
together but the scene later gets
retconned later on in the short the
consultant in this short Asian Coulson
tells agent sitwell that Stark was
actually sent in to use his famously
off-putting personality to deter Ross
who it seems wanted Abomination to join
the Avengers Stark's visit succeeded in
keeping abomination in prison but this
tells us that there's always been an
infrastructure of government
intelligence working against Thaddeus
Ross So as Thaddeus Ross steps into the
presidency and Captain America Brave New
World that is going to be the central
conflict a determined government leader
who won a tight control over super
soldiers versus a responsible government
apparatus trying their best to keep the
peace and re-watching this movie has
made me so excited for that fourth
Captain America movie okay that's it for
my re-breakdown of the Incredible Hulk
big thanks to our writers Gina I believe
and Jordan Morris for their help with
the script subscribe to new rockstars
the Deep dive and the break room and you
can support us for grabbing some merch
at nerd riot.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign